tanah abang in the center of Jakarta is
Southeast Asia's biggest textile market
the lead-up to the Muslim holiday of Eid
is usually the busiest time for traders
as customers come to buy new clothes
before the celebration this year is
different police have come to shut the
market down to enforce virus
restrictions opening their shots and so
the buyers keep coming it's not right we
will continue to enforce the social
restrictions and we will take actions
it's really tiring it's now a daily
ritual there are thousands of traders
here enforcing all of them to follow
regulations aimed at curbing the spread
of the virus is proving difficult if
they keep breaking the law we'll have to
revoke their business permit up until
now we've been trying to persuade them
the lead-up to Eid is a test for
Indonesian authorities the restrictions
mean that many businesses have been
forced to shut their doors at what would
normally be their busiest time of year
and some attempted to break the rules
despite the risk many here are daily
wage earners and some say they haven't
received any aid from the government if
we follow what the government is telling
us to work from home what will we eat
the virus might not kill me then but we
can still die from hunger crowds of
Jakarta's main airport this week
prompted criticism that the Indonesian
government relaxed restrictions far too
soon
only business travelers are permitted to
fly and only those who can afford the
increased air fares can make the journey
some feel low-income earners are being
disproportionately targeted I want
justice if you want to close my store
then close everything don't just keep
allowing wealthy people to continue and
force people like me to close they chase
us like we're selling stolen goods
just hours after the police raid this is
what the central market looks like
sellers putting out their clothing racks
again and returning to business as usual
that's a busy one I feel sorry for the
small sellers they depend on their sales
and what they earn they give to their
families it's hard and somehow now
bankrupt they know it's not allowed and
unsafe but they say they have no choice
but to stay open and earn a living
Jessica Washington al Jazeera Jakarta